it's a beehive of activity a warehouse
away from the front line full of
supplies to be delivered for those who
survived war and occupation
food basic necessities and glass replace
shattered Windows as winter approaches
this is our storage area for
humanitarian Aid it's all for the
liberated areas in the Curson region
it's dangerous for the volunteers they
could be shelling still that's why we
deliver directly to homes so we don't
have Gatherings of people there's a
sense of urgency as Ukraine continues to
inflict losses on Russian troops in the
South some of the trophies of War now on
display on the grounds of the school
where President Vladimir zielinski used
to attend
Ukraine has been announcing a sudden
offensive since the summer but then took
Everyone by surprise by making advances
in the kharkiv region in the north east
of the country it was believed that the
Russians have been reinforcing their
defensive lines in the South even though
recently Ukraine has managed to push
through some of them and regain some
territory the Ukrainian Army Advanced
from the north through the vast plains
filming there each step
here entering the village of status
India hoisting the Ukrainian colors and
removing the Russian claims to land like
here in novopetrica this woman says I
have been waiting for you for so long
her son is one of four regions Russia
has annexed a few days ago claiming the
majority of people there were welcoming
the move Terrace says it's untrue it's
not his real name as he is the
co-founder of a network of activists
known as the yellow ribbons who have
been carrying acts of civil disobedience
in russian-controlled regions
we're going to continue to document all
that's happening the collaborators and
the locations it's our protest our
activists will record everything and
send it out we do this to expose Russian
claims and hope that it helps our
authorities we will continue to
distribute Flyers
will continue to be delivered it's as
important as military achievements
Ukraine conveying the message that
people there were never forgotten
in southern Ukraine